hi friends I'm Alana and welcome to the
most awkward setup I think I've ever had
to wrangle on my channel but I don't
have a desk and this box is Lodge so
it's it is we have to make it work I
will be moving later in the video to
something that looks much nice up but
okay this isn't safe this whole thing is
crazy it's so cool for any of you who
didn't catch it I tweeted about it once
and have been posting about it on
Instagram a lot last week I got sent
this box crate I don't know what you
want to call it from PlayStation and
Kojima Productions it came padlocked the
only other things I got were this clue
which says Emily where's the answer and
has three dots one of which is yellow
the second one and then this letter
which does a much better job of
explaining stuff let me skim this for
you
so it's about how people built walls and
we need to make connections again which
is obviously a lot of the themes of
death stranding and then it says which
is why to help us celebrate the launch
of the game we're asking you to create
new bonds with jacksepticeye run punch
and Janina you have all received the
same package and it can only be opened
if you walk together each of you have
one piece of the puzzle these clues mean
little by themselves when connected
together as strands you will find you
have everything you need to open the
case we encourage you to also ask for
the help of your friends and followers
the more people come together the sooner
you'll see what's inside that's all I
got now I didn't know that I was going
to be getting this thing I did know that
it would arrive locked and I did know I
would have to work with those people but
that's it I didn't know what my clue
would look like I didn't know if we
would have the same kind of codes I I
knew very little and I think even if
they tried to explain it to me I
couldn't quite fathom what was going to
happen so it did this story very much
begins with getting this crate its pad
locked getting a clue that means
absolutely nothing by itself and having
no idea how to open it the part of the
campaign that was sponsored by
PlayStation was posting about this on
Instagram and an Instagram stories but
before we get into the details and how
we figured out how to open it and what's
inside because we have done all that I
did want to say they was so chill and
relaxed about if we figured it out ugly
so if we would figure it out a few days
before they accept
to us to which on day one they were like
we think we're all gonna figure this out
faster than we thought because the
community was sleuthing hard we didn't
have to stretch it we didn't have a time
frame but of course to all the comments
I got they were like why didn't you just
use a sledgehammer or bolt cutters or
why don't you just guess combinations
that seemed right until you get it I
didn't want to do that to ruin the fun
but I actually at one point was
live-streaming I started the stream by
saying no matter what happens I'm
knocking out within this case on stream
I was going over clues and asking the
chat for help but then people were
suggesting the same code over and over
and over again which did end up being
right and I was like I'm positive it's
not that based on like what I figured
out so far there's no way it's that and
I got maybe like halfway through putting
it in awkwardly because it was facing
like away from me and then I was like
you know what I don't want to do any of
this anyway without asking the others
because it was such a cool experience so
basically like I wasn't willing to just
brute force the numbers until I figured
it out I wanted it to be legit and when
the community was getting pretty close
to figuring out what the code was my
stance was you guys are guessing this
number if you can give me a reason why
this person's code leads to this number
in this person's code leads in us to
this number then I will put it in and
that's basically what happened for
reference the padlock is four numbers
says playstation like it's a nice
padlock actually and we didn't even know
if we would all have the same codes but
as soon as I saw we had four clues and
that they had something that implied
that it would probably be one number it
seemed obvious that we would have the
same clues okay new location so I can
pull some stuff up on my PC to show you
guys how this whole thing came together
and how we figured out what the code
actually was so it was my job to figure
out my code which makes sense I knew
Emily was the answer made this one of
the easier ones I think that me and Ron
probably had the easiest codes
oh it says Emily where's the answer and
it is three and then for my head first
went to red dress
realized dresses too many characters red
silk red gown it doesn't even really
matter what the second phrase actually
is because no matter what its read so
it's all edie right but then I
remembered Emily was a necklace
someone figured out some cool
information about lost year I think
polygon wrote something about it des
training sleuth decodes hidden musical
message in e3 trailer so Emily's
necklace that's what it looks like up
close obviously resembles an ancient
method of communication recording known
as quipu kojima tweeted about quipu so
as far as I'm concerned he knows what it
is and her necklace is intentionally
that and it gets better
so this is the original necklace and
then someone translated it into the code
I did not do any of this obviously the
code ends up being a melody to a song
called give me an answer by the Atlantic
band Laurel who Kojima seems to be
pretty obsessed with so basically it
turned out that if mine wasn't going to
be read something it was going to be low
role because Laurel also fits making
mine either E or o
so the PlayStation Instagram account on
the morning that we were set to post our
clues publicly they posted this which
was a cypher we kind of knew something
like this would happen we had no idea
what it was going to be a what it was
going to look like and wow I guess
people unjam baldies let us figure out
what these words were so this one's
rebuild this one is Porter that one is
obviously strand and then this
translated to help us connect if this
has helped us connect then it meant that
five which would be you know H ELP 5
equals e which would mean that if this
was read that there would be e now it
would be five if that's read it would be
e equals five if it is lower row it was
going to be zero so my code still don't
know exactly is either zero or 5 so
janina's didn't have any circles which
made her clue a little bit more
complicated initially but thinking about
it literally and trying not to be like
well why do hours have suckles and host
doesn't what does it mean just trying to
isolate hos I figured I think this would
this one was with the help of the stream
that it would be a three
initially I thought zero meaning you
started from zero Kojima tweeted about
starting from nothing he's said that
before where it comes to Kojima
Productions so I think that's why Janina
thinks it's houses zero so there was a
while where I was like positive that
house was going to be three four III
because III is EEE three e's III that's
when the game was revealed that's when
we want about des training realistically
if you look at the Sipho again he is
five so instead of it being about there
being three e's it is just e three times
it's five so that would make hers and
mine interchangeable zero and five could
be either of us it ultimately just meant
there was a variation of which number
was placed in which order when it came
to actually solving the clue but so then
Ron's might have been the easiest I
actually explained this here so his code
is easy to figure out basically there
was a trail up posted on 5:29 2019 and
if you go to 4:17 what you see is the
handprints of the BTS let me pull that
up you can see that I already searched
this and I have already looked at this
video
we know that the handprints of BT's that
had been announced already and that
stands for beach things which fits
perfectly in Ron's be e ACH D th I ng s
beached things and you can see my
comment here if I pull this over
according to the cipher it meant his was
too you can see that I wasn't sure about
this I did not even I would so refused
to believe that Jenny this was zero I
really thought it was three I actually
got screwed up on this when I was
streaming people kept telling me tried
2015 because we had figured out mine was
probably going to be 5 or 0 we figured
out janina's was was probably gonna be 3
5 or 0 I guess but I was like it has to
be in this order we knew that Ron's was
going to be 2 so I was just like there's
no way it can't be 2015 because that
would be 2z
one-five I was just so certain but that
didn't make sense because I was just
positive for whatever reason that this
would be the order that the codes was in
which obviously was wrong so we figured
those out Jax was lost and at the point
where I was confident that we had
actually figured out these three close
enough that we would be able to get
those codes unlocked and people were
telling me it was 2015 and I dropped the
notion this had to be in order and
considered 2015 but I wasn't really to
put the code in or even tell the others
we had a full group thread like I
mentioned and I was pretty far ahead of
them because I was reading all the
reddit threads I had done a live stream
to chat to everyone I was reading a lot
of comments I think I was like going
hard on this I didn't want to give them
any clues I wanted them to figure it out
but to people who were like try 2015
just try it you got halfway there just
finish it off I said if you can give me
a reason why you think that Jax is one
because we had two zero and five made up
elsewhere then I'll give it a shot Jax
was really tough we did not figure it
out the community 100% figured this one
out
that was his just super long one of
these is yellow I think you just can't
see it in this photo but um I had no
idea where to start him having the
Kojima Productions logo does make it
different but I legit was like I don't
know what that would be I thought that
it was going to be something on the
website so I was looking through the
Kojima Productions website that was a
poem at the start of one trailer we were
like maybe it's that but nothing fit and
again still don't know if these theories
are correct but what the internet ended
up assuming was that if you you know
such Kojima Productions and you finally
dance flip up toggle to open case cover
fits which is so weird that's such a
hard thing for us to figure out how to
connect so if it is indeed correct that
it is flip up toggle to open case cover
it actually made his P I believe
the P here would be help and that would
make it one which gives us in this order
1 0 or 5 2 5 or 0 and then once we had
that which again we really weren't sure
on Sean
/ Jax we really will like it's probably
this this is what everyone thinks it is
there was a while what people kept
saying 2010
I kept thinking 2013 in any given order
but by that point it was sort of a it's
probably this let's give it a shot so
that's basically how we figured it out a
lot of that was the help of the internet
so yeah then we put in our codes and
turns out it worked
ok so once we figured it all out it's
open time I when I opened it I think I
was the last to open it actually I
wasn't home and we'd been DMing and been
like ok we figured it out we're gonna
open it we're gonna do it you guys ready
let's do it but I decided to not use
social media for the rest of the day
until I was home to open mine because
they didn't want to have it spoiled for
me so I was just avoiding looking at
Instagram at all because I knew the
other people involved were posting on
their stories or their social media what
was in it so you'll understand how
freaking cool I thought it was why I
opened it these took me a really long
time to figure out that's these little
screw things that do that I've never
seen those before I was very confused ok
you guys ready for how cool this is the
second you open this thing up you can
see the lights on on it freakin lights
up I don't know why I'm so impressed by
that so I can explain all this stuff to
you this says deaths training
PlayStation and Kojima Productions
invite you to explore completely new
type of action game death stranding this
here so these things of which I have 6
ah I believe that called Cupid's and
they all have different formulas on them
and Sam who is the main character of des
training wisdom around his neck these
are basically things that are used to
connect the strands I want to say and a
USB which I actually check what's on it
yet then we have a ps4 controller a
joule shock that is designed to look
like the tank that the bb's kind of rest
in it's obviously translucent yellow the
touchpad has death stranding engraved on
it super cool I am so glad to have this
and of course PlayStation pros it's
beautiful says death stranding on the
front here it has hands from the BTS and
particularly love there's a little map
of the earth in the negative space down
here
shout out to Australia this is a thing
that I haven't seen before
what is this oh this is I haven't this
is my first time actually lifting this
out of the fall this is a necklace to
put those on that's cool also doubles is
a different display case for the Cupid's
so that's super cool also underneath
that we have more headphones always come
in handy and all the power cables well
both the box and for the ps4 so again
seriously this is one of the coolest
things I've ever been a part of
genuinely unforgettable experience I'm
so glad to have been part of it all of
this is amazing obviously I'm going to
keep this case I don't know where I'm
gonna put it when I'm to keep it but I
feel like I will cherish the fact that I
got to don't know in some way feel like
a part of the launch of death stranding
forever to everyone who helped us and
shared the excitement thank you it was
so cool obviously huge thanks to
PlayStation this video is not sponsored
so I don't have to disclose that
technically but of course this whole
thing was as part of an Instagram
promotion and thank you to Kojima for
making this crazy creative thing that
actually genuinely did bring people
together it was really cool all right
you guys sorry this video is kind of in
shambles I did the best with the
terrible setup that I have at home here
I'm Alana I will see you guys next time
bye bye